hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay we just got done beating the
ass of a monster and we got sucked into
a portal and oh my goodness that don't
look good let's um go the other way
first and that's about it we're on our
way to do something with someone to
somewhere and I don't really know who or
a wire how Tim stone there's a statue of
a guy alright looks like pretty much
standard fare so far definitely like the
design in the locale because I mean this
actually looks like some custom texture
work going on here I don't remember
seeing much of this they've got door oh
hello drill bit drill part oil hey I see
these other drill parts can I pick those
up and assemble them maybe seems like
something I need to do I still won oh I
have a padlock key I thought I had a
padlock nevermind let's try to get
through this as quick as possible
we got another room in here Connor rides
me towards the end of the actual amnesia
campaign there were these things that
you um insert your what is this insert
your sort of hand and donate some blood
or something this looks kind of
important I'm gonna assume that it is so
I'm gonna grab this maybe put it up on
this pedestal here chunk oh my god you
were kidding me I was right ah yeah holy
crap I don't know
I honestly god I had no idea that was
actually gonna do anything so I am
awesome yeah all right let's go see you
down here was that the water miracle
right as me frost was born from rock he
now fires an iron bolt into the rock
breaking it asunder and allowing life to
spring forth okay so what does that mean
here's a sledgehammer can I break rock
with this haha
they're so heavy ha oh ok apparently not
there's got to be something to do with
that orb that I just slammed into its
socket there maybe there's some other
thing I don't see another receptacle I
was kind of hoping that something would
happen more than it just slide into
place but see if we can do a few things
here can't do that no uh-uh
nah ah maybe if I had my knife the knife
that shouldn't have broke did okay the
Helio dramas right the son journeys
through the cosmos in a full circle
around the earth Mithras invites Sol
back to the center to reveal the
greatest glory of the world ok do I need
to get some sunlight in here is that
we're saying huh as something to do wait
what oh he's holding something
I thought his penis for a second there
was like wow wait a minute
sensor to the extreme ok maybe you need
this ha ha I don't know it's kind of
long and cylindrical shut up everybody
no don't oh don't you dare make jokes no
one make any jokes right now it's like
totally seriousness my hand I see a
little glowy ah not quite I can see it I
can see it I could see it right there
it's glowing I can use it for something
but what ah I'm so close yet so far I'm
on the right track I just don't know
what to do
eyeballs it's gotta be something else
that I've missed maybe something in this
room that I overlooked cuz I was just
kind of sprinting out oh man I feel like
I'm just right there I'm almost to the
solution and quicker than it ah ha yes I
knew there had to be something here we
finally entered the inner chamber this
entire structure must be buried several
hundred feet deep amazingly sturdy
baffled by the strange mechanisms the
hands of the two statues seem to
generate a powerful charge source cannot
rightly determine the inscriptions seem
to suggest charge glib with iron
conductor
all right center chamber stone door
incredibly strong mohandro broke without
inflicting so much as ass track Johan
houses a stone okay all right so we got
it yeah we got the piece we need to get
on with what we need to do sorry for
y'all I'm very excited today don't know
why okay you got that here you here
bread take this bread look Oh better get
out of the way
boom yeah what that do oh hello ah ah
well now I seem to have a mystical orb a
mystical orb that maybe unlock this door
Oh Devon thought who's going in there
balls I uh I thought that was it I
thought that was totally gonna be it ah
no way ah seems to like the light goes
out a NOS came too close to it
ah man I thought I have that I thought I
had that okay let me go
maybe the other during the pit that's
weird whenever I pass by those torches
sounds like fire were rushing by my ear
oh no the oh all the fires turned orange
that's it that's it
wait hang on let me just try down here
first all the fires have turned orange
ergo this lit the way I maybe I don't
know did that do it maybe now either I
put this back here and something 11 or
okay no no err go now Whittle open the
door if not then I'll be utterly
confused come on baby
yes yeah oh my god
I'm solving puzzles me me I'm solving
puzzles this is ridiculous
this is incredible hair it is but we
can't show this oh yeah just look at it
Samuel the Philosopher's Stone don't
touch it you don't know what it's
capable of yet you have to be very
careful
yes astute right uh-huh okay so now I'm
guessing it's just a shattered fragment
but that should be the last piece I need
I've got five pieces how many were in
the original amnesia I think five those
it no six maybe six I'm not sure okay
another level down let me just make sure
there's nothing sitting on the ground
man can you believe this me markiplier
is solving puzzles oh by himself ha ha
ha ah that'll battles that'll stop
pretty soon you can bet on that
oh man I'm just excited that I'm able to
progress on my own I seriously doubt in
read any comments from the last one I
read comments but nothing that would
help me through this okay so what's the
deal we got to sort of just plain ol
blockages here or anything down here
that I could actually use doesn't look
like it okay I guess I'm getting out of
here I got the piece of the orb I'm just
wondering if a monster's gonna suddenly
pop out out of nowhere and nibble my
face off
because that's usually the pattern I
progress a little monster nibbles my
face off maybe I could
maybe huh I needed string and tar to
assemble it before but maybe there's a
way maybe I have all the pieces that I
need maybe maybe I don't know
let me just double-check everything make
sure that I um didn't overlook anything
I'm just I'm just thinking like what why
was why was there one piece left here
anyway was it like I know that the guys
moved hearts around but I got ported
here by the darkness as far as I'm
concerned why would the darkness in any
way lead me to an or but I thought the
darkness was trying its hardest to get
the orbs back maybe it's trying to get
me to assemble the orb down there could
be who knows I don't I'm just stupid
markup err no I'm not I've now upgraded
to smart markiplier because I solved a
puzzle you guys are all like okay mark
don't get go ahead of yourself you're
like one for 999 let me try some okay
can't put them back ergo there must be
something down here that I can user do
or sudden Sun man what's the dealio here
ha JA ha JA ok none of these can go in
here I've got a drill bit for some
reason but why it doesn't make sense
don't tell me that I solved a puzzle
just to be confronted with a harder
puzzle let's zoom back to to just a few
few sentences a few minutes ago I was
like oh yeah oh so great I'll go stall
bubble little Lou but I can't solve this
puzzle and that's where we are today
gotta be soon soon
Tom Tom not right oh I totally forgot
that you could lean Oh
gotta be Sun some I'll drill through all
of this rock okay
balls what am I missing
what am I missing ah I made progress
I can't lose now it's not fair it's not
fair I had it I had it I've gone back to
every area what else do I need
maybe I don't know it's gotta be
something in that chamber down there
down here I mean because now the Mithra
or what the water of miracle right fires
an iron bolt into the rock iron bolt
drill maybe no okay there's got to be a
way for this iron way maybe there are
holes in here aha achoo ha ha how do i
fire that and let me well i can't pick
that up anymore
what why all right whatever oh oh maybe
aah
maybe I can get the UM the metal pieces
from the other guys and put them into
there and get them to fire it lay back
and maybe maybe maybe maybe baby baby
baby baby maybe maybe maybe please
please baby baby please yes
doesn't it I should have realized this
earlier but still solving puzzles you
can't be mad at me
I tried therefore nobody can criticize
me then oh right
get ready my iron soldiers or stone
soldiers fire
yes now stop it with the lightning
penises can I have these back now are
you gonna take it forever
damn that thing had some home I've got
my oar but therefore that's all I need
let's get out of here ah the material
was red and sticky and it seemed to be
pulsating it was only a remnant left
behind the creature that had attacked
them try as he might nothing hartleb did
could harm the material would forever
remain as a testament to their sin ah
oh boy here I go oh this looks good into
the darkness we go oh hello Maya I can't
believe it
I'm afraid mmm amazing don't get the
shape for all this time yeah it's safe
to go inside haven't come all this way
for nothing
oh hello keV oh hello I just fell into a
river I'm not a good thing and here
comes a waterfall whee ow ah I died ah
maybe I was supposed to go upriver
whoopsies my bad oh man that's just
silliness
okay trying again look oh wait almost
missed that Wow
parrot poacher paregoric paregoric
okay so good mentoring in here without
the blinding white light of old people
talking to me in my brain okay let's go
this way
whoa whoa can't go this way parently
currents too strong here we go there we
go okay hold on is that my voice talking
am I am i one of the people in this
whole circle I kind of suspected that
earlier but I mean what's the dealio
wait a minute what the am I supposed to
go up there I can't seem to where am I
wait a minute what's going on here I
don't have any rocks to push I'm about
to run out of oil whoa hello freaking
spider burn it with fire man okay Oh
what the hell what am I supposed to do
I'm literally about to run out of oil
here this is not cool and I'm actually
all out of time so um alright two
puzzles is maxed new record for
markiplier if you guys can tell me how
to get through this to the next part and
keep moving forward at a regular place
pace I will do that ah you [ __ ]
spider [ __ ]
JJ [ __ ] you okay so thank you all so
much watching click the annotations for
more videos that I've done except the
annotations are working at the moment
but they will be eventually I know the
plantations aren't working but I'm
trying every day
YouTube's kind of messing up at that
requirement so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
phone
Wow
holy still